foreign
[Music]
with season 11 just around the corner
you are probably aware that with this
update a couple of the raid Exotics will
now be able to be farmed in the dark
Zone but of course there is one thing
that hinders the happy farmer from
effortlessly running through the dark
Zone Rogues
so this will be a beginner's guide for
farming the dark Zone solo but these
tips will also help with a group
I won't be talking about PVP in this
video just what you can do to get the
most out of the dark Zone while avoiding
other players as much as possible I
frequent the dark Zone a lot mostly for
a change of scenery but I don't really
bother with the PVP side of things
because I find the division PVP system a
little bit weird
with this in mind I suggest running a
PVE build yes you'll be screwed if you
come across other players who want to
have a fight but the idea around this
video is how to avoid these situations
I'm an idiot and I like to run full DPS
with almost everything I do but I
wouldn't suggest this for everyone
instead I'd recommend a build with at
least a couple of million armor but
don't put too much into survivability
you need to be able to take down NPCs
relatively quickly so you aren't hanging
around anywhere for too long the
heartbreaker set is a good example of
decent survivability with high DPS
the skills are up to you as a solo
player you may want to run a reviver
hive but the Jammer pulse and decoy are
also very useful for distracting NPCs
when rushing through the landmarks
before diving in one of the biggest
thing you need to get your head around
is that whatever drops whatever you find
in the dark Zone that needs to be placed
into your contamination bag isn't yours
until you manage to extract it
until it's safely attached and flying
off in the distance underneath the
helicopter anyone has the chance to be
able to take it from you once you
understand and get your head around this
you'll have a much better time in this
area
trust no one
treat every player as if they're about
to turn on you even that solo player
running around minding his own business
has the potential to catch you off guard
and gun you down before you can react
and if you're there to farm you're
likely running a PVE build so you
probably won't stand the charts
it's cool if you want to team up with
other players and farm more effectively
but play it smart don't tell them if you
manage to find something amazing and
just be prepared for them to potentially
take everything you may get
it's not unheard of for players to
invite others into their team just to
boot them and kill them just before
extracting effectively making you a mule
to carry more gear
but don't get angry if this happens this
is the nature of the dark Zone yes it
can be frustrating that this is what the
dark zone is all about and like I said
the loot was never yours until you get
it onto that helicopter
if you're having trouble with other
players consider moving to another dark
Zone
in my region at least they are
particularly busy and even if this
update brings more players along these
are likely to be other PVE players so
let them draw the attention of the
Rogues while you do your best to stay
out of sight
another thing worth mentioning is to
look out for this little warning in the
bottom right hand corner it isn't so
important in busy servers but in quiet
ones we are stealthing around the map
seeing this means that players are close
and they can now see where you are
the same goes if you are running a pulse
while it might be nice to see what's
happening around you you'll also be
alerting them to your presence
I can't stress this point enough a large
part of successfully farming the dark
zone is knowing the map but this will
take some time and repetition
being comfortable with your surroundings
will help you both with anticipating
what's happening in front of you and how
to get away from potential threats
for example if you were to come across
an area and the NPCs aren't there it's
safe to assume that another player or
players are nearby same goes if you find
chests that have already been looted
because we're here for farming and not
PVP knowing where to run as needed and
quite important
you want to make sure you're not running
straight into a bunch of NPCs that will
slow you down
or maybe if you're feeling up to it you
do want to run towards NPCs and then
turn on the Rogues that will be getting
fired at from all angles
and at this point it's worth noting that
in the dark Zone you're gonna die to
start with you're going to die a lot
but this doesn't matter you may lose
some gear if you're carry but if not you
lose nothing
so use this
if you need to sacrifice yourself in
order to successfully extract gear do it
or maybe you just feel like finding a
faster way to the checkpoint
use every death as a learning experience
some can't be avoided but most of the
time it comes down to your situational
awareness and the way you react
[Music]
maybe you don't care too much for the
gear that can be farmed in the dark Zone
and that's fair enough there has never
been anything before these Exotics being
added that has driven me to farm the
area
however the DZ credits or resources can
be quite useful especially when the
vendor's reset and offer something that
you may have not been able to acquire
via other means
well there are a number of chests you
can get these from in the dark Zone but
this can be pretty slow instead I'm
going to refer to a video from sergeant
graybeard
I've said this before and I'm going to
say it again subscribe to his channel if
you would like to be kept up to date
with all things division he's also a
bloody nice guy he's one of those people
that I may never meet in real life but
will always consider a friend
and unlike so many he does this whole
YouTube Thing For the Love of the games
anyway this video offers a different way
of collecting DC resources one that I
wasn't aware of and have tried out
multiple times since
I highly recommend checking out his
video as it will give a far more
detailed description but I'll attempt to
sum it up
first create a new character
choose the main campaign not Warlords of
New York
run through the opening scene and get to
the base of operations
once you have jumped into the main game
after talking to many Etc go into the
store and select the level 30 boost
you'll then be loaded into the game with
a level 30 character
now you will be given a whole bunch of
level 30 high-end gear but to be honest
your build will be rubbish and this is
probably the largest thing you'll need
to overcome
from here you can start farming the dark
zones
these are the level 30 dark zones rather
than the level 40 ones you'll be running
on your main character
after trying this many times I still
haven't run into another player I was
able to farm happily deconstruct items
and extract without issues it was like a
PVE dark Zone
after you extract you can log back in
with your main character and find your
extracted items in the mailbox
now obviously the weapons and gear are
only level 30 so it won't be much use
that's why this is more suited to DZ
resource farming
deconstruct everything you pick up to
gain extra DZ resources and extract
like I said check out graybeard's video
this should be up in the top right
corner but I'll also have it in the
description
extracting is the hardest part of the
dark Zone putting up that flare
essentially announces your presence to
everyone on the map
this more or less comes under the know
the map section but if you are new to
the dark Zone I'd highly suggest
extracting a bunch of rubbish gear in
multiple different areas to start with
so you get comfortable with how it all
works
learn the layout of the map around the
extractions get an idea of where the
NPCs and even the players are likely to
come from you'll quickly find your
favorite extraction points to use based
on the available cover and Escape Routes
when you first fire the flare don't just
stand directly under it waiting for the
helicopter find a vantage point that is
as far away as possible that allows you
to watch over the area but still able to
abort and move on if needed
leave the NPCs if they are there they
will attack any players that come along
giving you a better chance of escaping
undetected if no players turn out throw
out your decoy to draw the NPC fire and
attach your items to be extracted
don't throw your items on as soon as the
helicopter arrives give it a while and
attach them in the last 30 seconds or so
it takes a while to cut the extraction
rope so if players arrive at the last
minute they'll either run out of time or
rush in completely open allowing you to
throw grenades and open fire
if your server happens to be busy you
may have to throw out some fake
extractions and keep moving around the
map until you feel comfortable depending
on how good your gear is it's likely
your patience will be far greater than
the Rogues chasing you around
these are just a few tips on top of all
mentions so far when running down the
street stick to the sides Don't just run
wildly down the middle even if you
aren't being chased break the line of
sight and keep obstacles in front and
behind you
keep an eye on the kill feed if you take
nothing else away this is one of the
most important tips the feed will not
only tell you that stuff is going down
but also how far away they are I
actually prefer a server where I can see
the Rogues running around because I know
exactly where to farm and where to
extract
you need to be cautious when farming
landmarks because when they're cleared
they'll appear gray on the map so
players looking for some PVP will often
look out for this and can often protect
your next move based on the landmarks
you've cleared so far
turn on your VoIP I was always against
this due to the saltiness and ridiculous
abuse being thrown out there by every 10
to 13 year old with a mic but with it
turned on you can often hear these
players coming from blocks away
particularly on console
if you're in a situation where players
show up while you're clearing a landmark
or even if you join in and help others
take down NPCs if you're worried about
getting jumped leave the gear on the
ground and don't pick it up it'll last
for quite a while so just leave it there
and move on you can always come back
later and get it
the dark zone is an ugly place for a lot
of players and this isn't without reason
but it needs to be seen as a high risk
High reward area
if you're getting ganked by players over
and over move to another dark Zone
the high reward aspect of the DC has
sort of been lost for a while now but
with the addition of these raid Exotics
we're seeing some changes here
I both love and hate the dark Zone and
as a solo player I believe this is how
it should be
I'm never going to be any match against
a team of four with half decent builds
coming against me but I can sure make it
difficult for them
as far as the potential for abuse goes
don't hold back from reporting players
who are going beyond what you would call
acceptable it may not have any immediate
impact but each report goes against the
player it may assist with them being
banned in the future but don't just ban
people who have absolutely destroyed you
in a fight this will definitely happen
save it for the people who are outright
cheating or abusing people
if you have any other tips for players
new to the dark Zone please feel free to
post them in the comments
I'm currently writing and recording this
in the middle of the largest weather
event New Zealand has ever seen during
my lifetime Cyclone Gabrielle
so we'll see how long it takes me to
have this recorded and put together and
uploaded I expect it'll be a little late
anyway I'm gonna go braid the elements
and attempt to cut down some more trees
that are looking to fall over and my
fence looks pretty rough plus maybe add
some more strops to the trampoline I
hope you found this video useful and
I'll catch you in the next one cheers
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]